if someone asked for a discount even if
they don't ask if you seed that you want
them to refer business to you say hey by
the way you might not know this but my
business is majority referrals and so
this is my price for you right now but
if you can send me two other people who
want to do whatever the thing is that
I'm giving you right now I have this
price and this is what 80 or 90 of my
customers actually pay you can buy this
now and I'll rebate you back this in
terms of extra work or I can give you a
straight check whatever works better for
you and also give your friend a discount
as well so they're not feeling like
you're pimping them out to just save
yourself money they're actually getting
a discount tip